you know got fat I see Pearl going out
there and doing the gym and you know
having a talk today about more not more
protein less carbs and all that so as
far as I'm concerned she's trying to do
something about it even though she got
cut back on all the cupcakes but she's
she's gonna he's gonna make us suffer
for it
he's gonna make us suffer for it but me
now
I got the same clothes
as when my son was young and what I find
to realize now is that I tried on the
dress the other day and he looked like
it was swallowing me I'm a size eight
the dress is a size eight and what I
realized now is that when I'm seeing
these fat people say oh yeah I'm a size
10 I figure you can't be a size 10. you
know what because the people that are
making the clothes are making a size 10
bigger so me now I can go in certain
places and I have to buy a size four or
size six I'm not a size four in a size
six I'm a size eight to ten I'm sorry